Speaker 1: Let's talk about something we've
discussed kind of anecdotally before, but not
not big picture. The TSA says that they
have confiscated a record number of firearms
from airline passengers at airports this year,
and you might be shocked to know that only some of
those confiscated firearms belonged to Republican
Congressman Madison Cawthorn. Only a partial joke
there. He actually did get caught trying to bring
up, bring a firearm on board, getting it through
secure, trying to get it through security.
Just a few months ago, let's discuss the data.
Passengers are bringing a record number of guns
to the airport. TSA says airline passengers are
bringing guns to the airport in numbers never
seen before, and it is a quote huge problem.
Security and law enforcement officials are at the
same time dealing with an unprecedented surge in
belligerent passengers, straining the systems
designed to designed to keep air travel safe.
We've had more incidences where don't they mean
incidents? We've had many. We've had many more
incidences where there are passenger disturbances,
both in checkpoints and onboard aircraft. That
makes it more important that there are no guns
involved, says TSA Administrator David Paczki.
TSA reports catching 4600 firearms at checkpoints
in the first 10 months of the year. A majority
of which were loaded folks loaded firearms in
airports that surpasses the full year record of
44 32 from 2019. So we've still got the rest of
October, as well as November and December, and
we're already several hundred firearms beyond the
record. With 11 weeks left in the year, including
the busy Thanksgiving and Christmas seasons, the
number will reflect an American population that
is increasingly armed. I think more people are
carrying weapons just generally across the country
and then whatever is happening across the
country we see reflected in our checkpoints.
As a passenger, I don't want another passenger
flying with me with a gun in their possession.
Yeah. The agency is also finding guns at a faster
rate than it has ever experienced during the
lows of air travel during the pandemic in 2020.
Transportation security officers confiscated a gun
from about 10 passengers every one million.
This year, they're finding 11 armed passengers
in every one million. 80 percent 80 percent of
the firearms were found loaded. No checkpoint,
no airport is immune from having passengers tried
to carry guns through the checkpoint. It does
occur more frequently in again the states where
gun carriage is at a higher rate compared to other
states. You know, there are people who react to
these stories. And in fact, Republican Congressman
Madison Cawthorn said exactly this when he was
caught. The explanation was the justification was
it was an honest mistake. I didn't realize
that the gun was in my carry on. That
is negligent action if you don't. What are the
main things about firearms? Keep them unloaded,
keep them safely stored and know where they
are. If you believe your gun is unloaded at home
or unloaded in your checked baggage and
it's actually loaded in your carry-on,
that is negligence and you
shouldn't even have that firearm.
The justification the excuse that they use is
actually something for which they should have the
ability to have that firearm removed. If you can't
keep track of where your loaded firearms are.
You don't have any business owning a gun aside
from anybody's views about the Second Amendment
or background checks or whatever. When you say,
Oops, I didn't think the gun was in my carry-on,
then you didn't know where it was. And that's
negligence, and it's a responsible gun ownership
not knowing where your gun is. And it's a
frequently used excuse, but it's not really
an excuse. It should actually make us say, Whoa,
we should. We've got to look into that more.
The article goes on to say firearm finds by TSA
workers create an inconvenience for fliers during
a time when more people are looking to travel
again. Yeah, it's more than an inconvenience.
It's actually a sort of an existential threat.
A firearms 80 percent loaded. Gun discovery,
slow checkpoint lines trigger a local or airport
police response. Airline officials, meanwhile,
are asking airport police to be proactive about
spotting intoxicated or otherwise agitated
passengers who may spark an in-flight disturbance.
Yeah, we've talked about this as well. Those
unruly passengers are also at previously unseen
levels. It's sort of like a pandemic induced
psychosis that we're seeing is it's it's wild
what is happening at airports? I how many times
have I flown during the pandemic? I guess three
roundtrip flights and all of the stuff I saw at
the U.S. airports. Part of it was at international
airports. Everything I saw at U.S. airports,
there was wacky behavior, wacky behavior. And this
is this is, by the way, beyond just people playing
fast and loose with the mask rules like holding a
glass, the entire flight to be in the process of
drinking and keeping their mask down and stuff
like that. I'm talking about just belligerent
people, drunk people, loud people, people
screaming. It's it's not good. It's not good.
What's going on? And certainly adding firearms
to that mix would only make it much, much worse.